[Música]
aquí comienza a ella soy de france 24 el
7 de abril se conmemoró el día mundial
de la salud a propósito de la fecha
abordaremos los prejuicios y
desigualdades en la atención médica a
las mujeres a las comunidades diversas y
a las minorías a grandes rasgos la
medicina es una ciencia desarrollada
históricamente por y para hombres los
estándares clínicos se crearon a partir
de la patofisiología masculina dejando
fuera las singularidades del cuerpo
femenino al momento de diagnosticar
enfermedades y de ordenar tratamientos y
por otro lado hablaremos del gas
lighting un tipo de violencia médica que
se atribuye a los síntomas con
condiciones psicológicas y estados de
ánimo llevando a menos los síntomas y
provocando malos diagnósticos
vamos a conversar con sandra castañeda
coordinadora general de la red de salud
de las mujeres en latinoamérica y el
caribe se conecta con nosotros desde
armenia colombia y también nos acompaña
desde sonora en méxico la doctora lucero
aída juárez de herrera y cairo médica
con especialidad en pediatría de la unam
e investigadora de género y salud
ciudadanía y salud sexual y reproductiva
bienvenidos ambas a ellas hoy comienzo
con la doctora lucero porque necesitamos
perspectiva de género en salud y como
ejemplo quisiera que conversáramos sobre
uno de sus temas de investigación las
disparidades en la enfermedad coronaria
claro que sí gracias por la invitación
muy bien la investigación sociocultural
en salud ha evidenciado que persisten
inequidades y seis los de género en el
campo médico para la atención integral
de las mujeres y bueno de las personas
lgtb y pumas y que esto es un proceso
violatorio de derechos humanos de
derechos en salud además hay
condicionantes sociales culturales
económicas y políticas que incrementan
la vulnerabilidad de estos grupos
poblacionales de tal modo que hay en su
interior podemos encontrar riesgos
diferenciales en salud diferentes
maneras de vivir el proceso
salud-enfermedad de atención y de
gestionar sus necesidades en salud
las enfermedades no son sólo
construcciones biológicas son también
construcciones sociales culturales
históricas que se ligan a modos de vida
a interacciones y a relaciones sociales
y de género bajo diversas condiciones
económicas y políticas
sumado a esto podríamos decir que en el
campo médico el poder es una dimensión
clave de tal manera que el sistema
médico frecuentemente reproduce
inequidades y jerarquías
por ejemplo al natural izar y normalizar
las inequidades a través de imágenes y
hechos del cuerpo no cabe señalar estas
desigualdades de género se comprenden
cuando se relacionan con textualmente
con otros procesos como la pobreza el
desempleo la etnicidad el acceso a los
servicios médicos la concentración de la
riqueza etcétera no de manera que para
comprender las bases sociales más
profundas pues es necesario analizar y
comprender cómo y por qué las
diferencias biológicas de las
enfermedades se convierten en
inequidades de género en este sentido en
la investigación que hicimos sobre
enfermedad coronaria en mujeres con
perspectiva de género
encontramos varios
aspectos no uno es la larga
invisibilidad de las mujeres de la
propia medicina como ciencia que mónica
otra es la clasificación de los síntomas
de las mujeres en algunas enfermedades
repito como la enfermedad coronaria pero
también se empieza a vislumbrar ahora en
el quabit 19 como enfermedades o
síntomas inespecíficos o atípicos porque
porque están estudiados en el típico no
y el cuadro típico sería el masculino
claro esto contribuye a la perpetuación
del desconocimiento de cuáles son los
síntomas y signos más específicos para
las mujeres claro luce además hay un
reduccionismo biológico en disculpé
llanero es la grulla de interrupción era
de lucero perdóneme es que quisiera
también hablar un poco con sandra sobre
el tema y se nos va muy rápido todo el
tiempo que tenemos de programa
y sandra precisamente sobre esto que nos
habla el lucero esta persona está
demostrado que el personal de salud por
ejemplo en los años 90 realizaban menos
esfuerzos diagnósticos en mujeres que en
hombres con enfermedad coronaria en
cambio los síntomas eran tratados con
ansiolíticos como si estuviéramos
padeciendo ansiedad este es uno de
muchos ejemplos de gasa lighting en
médico tanto hemos mejorado en tres
décadas
pero si muchas gracias en realidad en
digamos en todos en todo el sistema de
salud mismo lo que hemos visto es que es
claro el diferencial que hay en la
atención para hombres y para mujeres y
no solamente en la fase diagnóstica es
que en a lo largo de todo el proceso de
manera permanente las mujeres viven de
manera diferente el digamos el acceso a
la salud el acceso a la salud para las
mujeres sigue todos los patrones de
discriminación que los demás aspectos de
la vida y recordemos que las mujeres en
general en américa latina
son más pobres que los hombres en
general las mujeres cuentan con menos
tiempo porque el trabajo de cuidado de
la familia le ocupa muchísimo tiempo
mientras que las mujeres bueno estos son
datos de antes de la pandemia mientras
que las mujeres
dedican tres veces más tiempo a las
labores domésticas que los varones
además están en situación de dependencia
de falta de autonomía económica falta de
autonomía física y a esto pues le
sumamos los estereotipos que pesan sobre
las mujeres las discriminaciones por
raza y por clase todos los estereotipos
la violencia contra las mujeres y el
sistema de salud no es una excepción
siguen siendo todas las formas de
maltrato de dependencia de subordinación
y de exclusión que vivimos las mujeres
en casi todos los aspectos de la vida
pues vienen se reproducen en los
sistemas de salud y se reproducen
claramente en los en las en todas las
fases de la fase de diagnóstico por
supuesto y la de tratamiento es a
engordar pero pero pero mire es que está
muy claro que la carga emocional y
psicológica de la mujer en la vida
diaria es más fuerte que la del hombre y
un ejemplo perfecto de eso es américa
latina con las tareas de cuidado pero
eso no significa que cuando una mujer va
a una consulta
necesariamente está para decir me estaba
padeciendo una enfermedad o unas
situaciones de dificultad mental o
psicológica que es lo que pasa muchas
veces y ahí le quiero preguntar por esos
diagnósticos erróneos las mujeres
tenemos mucha más posibilidad que los
hombres lamentablemente de ser mal
diagnosticadas por lo tanto nos dan
medicamentos que no corresponden que
como le decía antes muchas veces tienen
que ver con ansiedad tardan más en
descubrir las enfermedades y pues eso
nos pone más cerca de la muerte cuando
no debería ser así
claramente es que
esos errores de diagnóstico también
tienen que ver primero porque
digamos que también el sistema de salud
en muchas quejas por eso porque la
atención que las mujeres tiempo que las
mujeres destinan al cuidado de su propia
salud es mucho menor entonces en los
procesos en los tratamientos en la
asistencia a citas en mantener la
regularidad de los controles muchas
veces están interrumpidas porque las
mujeres no disponen de autonomía para
manejar su tiempo en un tema entonces el
personal de salud o el personal médico
muchas veces se queja que las mujeres
interrumpen los tratamientos que no
quieren ir a los controles que no
quieren presentarse a las citas que
muchas veces tienen que ver con la gran
cantidad de tareas de cuidado de otras
personas que tienen tiene que ver con la
falta de recursos para para desplazarse
para pagar transportes para salir
recordemos que una gran parte de las
mujeres en américa latina y el caribe
habitan en sectores no
es una población muy grande que tiene
dificultades para moverse y la salud no
llega hasta allá como son las mujeres
las que tienen que llegar hasta los
centros urbanos donde están los
servicios de salud para las mujeres es
muy muy complejo de manera que para él
para el sistema de salud muchas veces es
más fácil dar un diagnóstico de esta
naturaleza que entregarle los recursos a
las mujeres que facilitar el acceso y
con eso con un diagnóstico fácil con un
diagnóstico sencillo con un casi siempre
equivocado vamos a resolver un problema
que que tiene que ver con causas
estructurales que tienen que ver con la
pobreza con el aislamiento con la falta
de autonomía con la aic con la
sobrecarga de trabajo que tenemos las
mujeres y sé que eso conlleva
acetaminofén cada 6 horas pero entonces
el lucero otro buen ejemplo del que
usted ha hablado y muy rápidamente se lo
pregunto y que lo ha evidenciado la
pandemia las vacunas de kobe 19 lo hemos
hablado hasta el cansancio en france24
como las mujeres tenemos síntomas
diferentes cuando nos aplican las
vacunas y es que nosotras no fuimos de
como ejemplo para el desarrollo de las
vacunas seguimos con el estereotipo del
hombre blanco dentro de los ensayos
sí claro
uno de los grandes problemas aparte de
los que nos comentaban ahorita pues es
que precisamente el modelo androcéntrico
de las enfermedades estructura el
conocimiento sobre las mismas y no sólo
es en relación a las vacunas lo que está
empezando a evidenciarse es que nuestros
síntomas y signos efectivamente pueden
ser diferentes en la enfermedad se
siguió estudiando más en hombres blancos
como bien dicen pero además están
sacando evidencias de que las
diferencias no son solo fisiopatológicas
o sea una ley no pues las hormonas eso
decían lo mismo con las enfermeras y
cardiovasculares no que el proceso
inflamatorio es diferente las mujeres no
pero hay serias desigualdades de género
por ejemplo hay algunos reportes que ya
están diciendo que las mujeres aunque la
enfermedad es más letal hay más
probabilidades de morir que los hombres
las mujeres tienen menos probabilidad de
ingresar no al hospital en sí pero sí a
las unida de cuidados intensivos y de
ser incubadas en las formas más graves
todavía hace falta un análisis más fino
no por ejemplo donde están falleciendo
donde han fallecido durante la pandemia
en sus casas tienen más probabilidades
de llegar al hospital sí o no pero las
estadísticas pues también invisibilizan
las desigualdades porque no sólo es
desagregada por sexo el número de
muertes que en algunos países hasta eso
ha tenido problema de hecho acaba de
salir un estudio en américa latina'
y bueno empiezan a verse diferencias si
por sexo por género pero también por
ejemplo por etnicidad bienestar lo
comentaba no si hay problemas entre
hombres y mujeres por ejemplo en la
realización de las pruebas diagnósticas
en el ingreso a los hospitales en las
maneras en que se vive la enfermedad sí
pero inclusive en la probabilidad de
ingresar a una terapia intensiva esto
todavía es más marcado en los grupos
minoritarios por razones de etnicidad
por ejemplo no y no es nada más que la
pura verdad verdad muchísimas gracias a
ambas de gracias el lucero gracias a
sandra por estar con nosotros o por
darnos argumentos clínicos médicos
científicos de por qué hay desigualdades
en la salud cuando las mujeres somos las
que tenemos acceso y se nos quedan por
fuera varios temas que seguro serán para
otro programa la bordó fobia y el ser
mujeres funcionales todo el mes pese a
que cinco días del mes al menos
estaremos sangrando con nuestro periodo
menstrual gracias a ustedes ya nuestros
televidentes por estar con nosotros
sigan en france24 y nos vemos
próximamente en ellas hoy
[Música]